So really you ride a horse
to school every day.
Yeah
but only for a year old because then i
think i might have them before they wanted
it back because their own
children were going to school
and it was a long way to school.
How long have i do you think.
Well i'm up to one because
it seemed a very long way
but then i was i was young but i would
say that it had to be too much of them
or more and down a steep hill
and then two times a week we'd have to
go from coffee camp to bishop's creek to
pick the my lap which would be another
two mile and then up a human game.
So it was when we had no shoes and
never wore shoes i don't know
but you know winter and summer.
Yes i can remember wearing shoes and when
they took the horse back. He walked.
Oh yes some of the dork brother was to
be going. My sister and he went to you.
So i think she would have left and you
know on the brother matthew bell and
that was down and how what time in
the morning which is all right.
And remember that it had to be fairly
early because it was a long way
and what do you what time did i like
my 9:00 to 3:00. So i'm emotional.
Find me. And.
How many kids went to so
we're not going to remarry
and probably it's been
20 something like that.
I can't remember we were the only 10 you
know i had no problem at all because of
the time i went to school i could
speak english you did your brothers
and sisters having.
To teach you to play them
a bit i think it was more
that they were trying to speak
italian. But of course.
Not knowing what they were saying
my brother got into a few scrapes
and i can remember. Actually this was
when i was going to school the
teachers school teachers.
School teachers mr. doyle and he had a
little of you know we had kids believe it
or kid he was and my brother was real.
Nearly you know football and type
and this little kid timing they most was
teasing him. So we picked him up and.
Much as i downed in a fresh power pack.
I had and when he turned him
around again it was a mess
and he ran screaming back to his father
and lunchtime minimum back to home.
And i think out shouldn't
do that to begin with.
I disagree with their disciplinarian school
teacher now it was pretty good really
easy was pretty good and.
When i think you put a lot.
I think it's a realize that we
were italians and because of
that he helped us sort of
thing you know and i put up.
Yes we probably put up with what he may
not have done with another another child
probably that's just my impression of it
and what he did you really are just
my mind just gotten dresses you know
you know the left and you know no
you know for nobody in uniform.
You know and the kids in
news. They all had cotton.
I mean they're all really poor people.
Do you keep in touch with any of those
children that you went to school with
when it is you know
them from time to time.
Not anymore no longer referendum school.
No i'm saying the wrong thing.
I don't actually kept in touch
but strangely enough one.
No those boys
that went to the school now live in
the street in robotham yeah yeah and
but this is really used to go to
school but you know i haven't.
I haven't actually kept in touch but
we made up. I have also so going now.
Recently i joined the bonsai society
and through that i met another girl
and went to scale them on a sweep.
She was then so but actually having
kept contact with them you know
and you know you know
you know well i left.
Actually left there when i
was fairly young. To go.
You guys school will
probably come to that later.
We didn't go to the christmas trees i
remember going to the christmas tree there
which was absolutely magic for me because
i had never seen things like my life
and one time one year old
in the most beautiful
when broidered handed
with unbelievable to me
and another time i was
given a little doll which.
The first of i'd ever had in my life
and i thought it was so beautiful.
Until my brother met little.
Tummy open to see what it was you know
and it was straw and i cried and cried.
I didn't want my doll they
have stolen it coming
and i don't know what happened with a
dolphin unc they'll probably pick step up
tell me more about the christmas night
what did they do because well it sort of
played games and things like that.
You know and santa came which was to me was
just something you know nothing unique.
And no one none of them and none of
them what experience you know in
that anyone who did they have what
kind of christmas celebration.
If they don't think they have very much.
Although the reason name for santa claus
but it's really the family
which means a life.
But i mean when you're poor you don't
have christmas inside and things like.
Just try had you to have
special known extra street.
You had sort of special days
when they made what we call cross to
me which is a really a pride biscuit
and that's a special occasion weddings.
They still have them a friend
and i have made prolonged
weddings made of course not
that i'm any good only i'm good at cooking
on special of cooking you want to seem
like crossley that i like to
take but i can't make them.
Did your mother teach you
how well she probably did
but we didn't have any machines to me
only out of the bottle. To do them then.
So they would they were
more or less the same.
Yes that was special occasion
and another special occasion they made a
torta a which is nothing like the taut age
they were made here but it would made
with blood that they caught from the pigs
and in even a grimace.
I have since time an aunty has since
made it here and i agree with you.
I take
that you know i put in the door as if
it was a widget to grab in my mouth.
But it's quite nice.
You mention you mentioned and i
notice that your home to your mother.
Your husband he or i don't
know side of the family.
Well i haven't got any aunties so it
would have to be my husband simon and me
and i don't have any you know your father
and mother had no other relatives
you know you know no time.
Do you do you did your mother and
father keep in contact with.
Oh yes yes yes mum wrote
to them right up to me
and you know they did have
contact with are you.
Not me personally but the family.
Do you have a lot of relatives to
be cousins now yes i did see them
when we went back in 78.
But i didn't really know
with them and i found that.
I was more astray liam and what i thought.
Did you feel terrible and yes i
completely a foreigner. Yes.
Did i understand you find.
Oh yes we still speak the same dialect
even here you would have a and
and trailing accent no i probably didn't
they never said anything they understood
you know you are you know no
problems and no tell me about.
Truth. You know. Oh well
that that's going yes back to just
recently we had the chestnut night.
Well it was a tradition in italy.
That was one of the things
that they did have was
when the chestnuts were ripe they would
cook them on coals you know over the
burning coals and they'd have a
party drinking wine and chestnuts
and it happened that it would
be about ten years ago now.
We'd play bowls and our team and one
when with no one expected us to win.
You know and i was so thrilled about it
that i think i why don't we celebrate
and so we said we'll celebrate
up our place which is here
and then it sort of went on
from there and some was there.
Well why don't we make it a
chestnut night which we did.
And we had all these people came.
I think original ones would
have been the ones that
when the committee with the indoor bowlers
and it was strange to me i sort
of sat back and look at them
and they're saying this
is great. This is great.
It's just like it was to be and
it brings back all those memories
and they were reading all these
chestnuts we got our very much.
Anyway wasn't very impressed.
Where did you get the just such.
That came from sydney
a friend of the three
but having those actually have
your board meeting sent them up
and what we do then would prove
them they preach quite well.
Then take me out of the night raised
them but we turned it into a barbecue
and it was you know a good view but i
can still remember the first night.
The older italian the hair
of filmy were you know.
And did you have that when your child
if you happen to know you know
that on the first one probably thinking
my god. Taking on me like really.
You could a very expensive and
know you know in the book
and tell me about the washing up kids.
Oh yeah that was a work of art
and this is to be a kerosene tin
and i can't remember
how you cut it exactly
but i think it would cut
it on the top and bottom
and then the side leaving only one
side and cut so that you could open it
and it would give you two triangles around
that they would put board so
you wouldn't cut yourself
and one was used for washing
and one type of washing up
and one type of anything which
made it through thick thin
and we also had one of those for washing
ourselves you know not our bath
but our hand. Yeah because we had
we didn't wash our hands inside
and we had a little bench outside like
a laundry tub. It sort of yeah yeah.
It made too little tub
and everyone had those.
Because there are times when useful i
think the english community as well.
I see you know now i mean to me
but then i must admit i didn't
go into the hands of the english
but i don't know where they
landed from because they have.
They had it when we when i arrived but i
mean i can remember said what is right
and you know i don't know
having a shortage of water
or having to be careful with the water.
Did you do the dishes once a day or you
know i think they were done every day
and
that was what you want to because you're
looking at a thousand gallon tank for a whole
family so that it might save
lives. Any water washing about it.
We put on the venue. I can remember i
tell you about our little army after
that what we did what i
would do like the vision
that would first be rinsed out and any
sort of scraps that came up your clothes
and that went towards the
feed from team. You know you.
So everything with nothing was wasted.
Nothing and that with
that water situation the way it was
did you wash up after every meal
or save the dishes to no
one i remember we used to.
We used to wash up every day but the
thing is that if it really rain short
or before it rain sure that actually you
would get your water for washing up
and for washing engrams from a creek
or from a well i think we might have had a
well up there. But a countryman recruit.
So like you have you would have to
get water from somewhere because
that wouldn't do you say you when you're
running low temp kept a program thing.
Tell me about the the people.
Oh yes our salaaming we assume
they could i think bought a little
pig from a farmer small
pin and we feed it.
So it wasn't what it would use that
and a normal item for myself to have.
Oh it was really amazed with
a pig an expensive item.
Well it wasn't a very expensive item because
it was boardroom in there it's more
and you write yourself you
have a little peep in
and any of the scraps from the pigeons in
before you go towards the pink feeding it
then we grew our own corn.
So that was fed to it
and then the wife from after making a
record to change all the changes so
that it was really inexpensive.
To feed and it was very large
we kept it for about a year
and it was very large at the end
of the year. So then kill it.
And of course as children were. Made
to go away when they killed it.
But are you to take one peek i think i
mean i didn't think it was very nice.
Anyway so i never looked again but.
Then it would be made into
sausages and salami the sausages
and there was nothing
that was called could begin to
which you made with the end of the
meat that wasn't the best and
you put the stack surely means
that the skin of the rind
on the peat would be mad
and we made the sausages in the court to
give me family salami the subdivisional
reason was made with the meat
that had a bit of blood
on it with something
and they wouldn't go in a very short time
because they wouldn't keep very long.
But the salami in the quality would
have to last you practically all year.
And they had no
preservatives in it at all.
So what they did was they
dug a hole under the house
and they put boards around
it and turned into a cellar.
I think out cellar had from when i
can remember it was under the house
and the floor of the house
was the top of the cellar.
But i was talking to my
sister the other day
and she said a really really first one
which i don't remember was a big box
and the farmer how i was in the
ground and a big box was put there
and we kept the salami. But
i don't remember that.
So we put it in me and it had to
be like the coolest you could any
when it rained of course
water when he bought it
but you have to take the salami out
take them up inside and then you bail
or water out the sunnis in finished
raining it help and when it was dry.
Nothing put them back in the game because
it was very important that they be kept.
Because they were things
that we had to have known you know i
mean you have the same for all here and
that was enough to keep well yes. Yes.
As we got better
and a bit more wealthy we have two pings
which would actually last two years. Yeah.
And of course again it is something
that you cook actually cook it.
You don't eat it raw you cook at
wherever salami that actually raw meat
that you're reading. And you
would. Yes it would dry out.
I imagine dry you know even
dry out you know it didn't.
Those fellows were nearly
better than the ones.
Later on you know what it would it would
be it would get a mold over it and
that would help keep it dry and i think
you had to keep that women away from it.
Otherwise that would dry it out
but no it didn't write to dry out
in those days at all and the.
Tell me about the cooking. You know
what do you think happens now.
Well if you have the sinews and
that of your meat you know the meat of lower
legs which is you don't want to miss a
mummy because that they're
not very nice to eat raw.
So you put all that and then you get
the rind from the pin that means all
that up by hand you know we have a mensa.
Actually i think mum took it from me.
Police took a lot of things from
italy and they would mince that up
and they would put foot into it to claim
that land you believe
skinned i think there.
And it was actually one lamb would give
you one skin because it's the appendix so
that you wouldn't have to tie the bottom
but the bottom is it's already round
and you put it in very tightly
a pack a tight as you could.
And a lot of them used to burst.
Because you'll be packing
of really tight to keep it
and then you're tied on top
put three strings around
and tighten again put a lot of how you
know one knew somebody forgot to put holes
in of my all burst like balloons and
i think that when your relatives
and then you hang them up to dry you
hang my up in the kitchen actually.
And two all the water and
soap out of them all before.
Yeah i don't do that that
these days and i haven't done
that alarm out of no matter what.
The pretty well i've lasted longer salami.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah because that removes
skin so that while to one pickles and.
You. That got him a year
would be a pretty big thing.
Did you need to pick any special
things people who know.
You know it was getting all natural things
which is why the salami was so nice.
The salami today are not
near what we have been.
Because now they've got
preservatives in them
and they feed them all these unnatural
to you know interesting morning to.
Mr.. Rennet the main.
Source of income few
father was bananas with it
when i guess it was in the nana's
and that we starting to be.
Shortly after we came i think.
And as i said before there wasn't
a road up to the plantation.
So they'd have to be carted with a
stick or some spring cardboard chap
that i remember is me
he would pick them up
and take them to a top of a very steep
hill and send them down on the flying fox
and the bee the carrion jack ran
from in them with the carrier
and he'd write down on the coffee came
right. And he'd stop them down there.
Put the money truck and take them into
the railway to be sent to sydney.
Yes well i remember one time somebody dared
somebody to go down on the flying fox.
I wasn't there to see it but i believe he
went down and when he got to the bottom.
He was so why do you find it
really memorable you know.
You know it was very long and very deep you
know occasionally sometimes occasions.
My thing. Stopped in time
something the kindly
that we broke in the not a lot of it was
work on the system and something down
and then something up. I think. But i
don't think that we can do a very steep.
Do you remember. What price between
like in those days for the price.
Well the prices for those days
and for a long time after actually i think
in those days they might have been a bit
better than they were later
when i got out of sort of 10
or 12 that were later they weren't
that bad that sometimes you might
send 30 40 cases and bananas
and they were bigger cases
and what we have now.
And you get maybe you have
a dozen penny stand back.
So you get nothing out of
that you had your production costs which
in your case to start off with the carrier
make to carry them over to the
top. Yes. So it was very hard.
The only way we actually did lead was
because we were pretty self-sufficient in
and at the time you know the workings
that you had to buy and from
when inside could remember there
was a shopkeeper in town.
J a meringue and jam iranian he had
a shop. You know in the street.
I think
that he was going over to the railway station
he had a shop there for a long time.
He later moved to.
Would love street with the
imperial bottle shop is now
and he would give credit
to the italian food
and he carried it would carry
the month after month you know
and probably wouldn't even ask for money
because in you know didn't have any anyway.
And i also knew that it's anybody
could they would pay them and that
when they planned the
beans and things like
that they would get some money in beans
and vegetables were rather good proposition
in those days because there being no
frozen food or no canned foods.
They would be came to see me in them in the
winter months where they couldn't grow
them down there so much and
they would be worth money.
That's how it made me how
they survived i think.
And in the very first time
when they planted the bananas.
They were planned they actually planned to
being in between the bananas which would
give them a very quick quick make use of
the land in the quick cash crop nothing of
life that no no no you had to really
what are the vegetables. Did you go.
I think we grew just about everything
but taters to martin he being you know
hearty member a lot of vegetables.
Did you know flavoring like her.
Now the only prim i can remember was raising
me because you didn't need me anything
and i think i would grown up with that
word and hear a lot of time in the amount.
And. How old were you when
you moved from coffee cans.
I was 10 i think we went and you got
but i actually changed the school and
went to the gym by school before
that because that ended banana did
you guys. And so after that up.
We started my brother
and i started going to dubai school which
was a long way away to learn about four
miles and how did you
get all involved there
and you know like later on the.
Did you find your brother
and his brother your ship
and they walked over to you dave and
well. Yes they would have had to.
I always remember well know
that they the house was built like you
know down the july which was a big
improvement on the house we had up here at
the top of the problem by which we call
gun alley. How much there would
have been a road by now. So it.
Probably would have gotten i think
they might have had a horse
and they would have got a ride.
Sometimes with a carrier up talking of the
carrion later on we did a ride to the
farm and the carrier come and took
them bananas and he was the only way
that our family had of
getting to town the carrier
and i remember one time
as always in my memory
when my sister was pregnant
really well advanced too
and she had to go probably
to the doctor i don't know
and the only way to go with it
was with a carrier. So this guy.
My mother went to my mother had been sick
for a long time so she was in sitting
in the front and his mother went to
the center of my room to my sister
and also she had to sit on
top of the load of bananas
and i think it made a sort of little pocket
for a deceiving you know like the case
out of something
that she was sitting on top of maybe 200
cases of the none of them pregnant.
But that was lucky she was probably one
of the lucky ones made up there you know
but. And.
Did your father built the house
to go yet they helped you on
that i think they got
someone to help them.
And they built it into the bigger house.
How different was back to
the place well i think the
board was still overlapped in the years
and i might have been changed later
it was bigger it will bigger
or so we had a dining room
there which was you know.
Big thing in the dining room
and it was close to the school
which made living much easier.
And how many were well once again there
would have been there was the room
and mum and dad and the girls and
the boys still slept on the veranda
and yes the boys were still on the
green and kitchens in some areas.
Yes we had a kitchen and a better.
Fire place in the bathroom
on the corner of the brain.
But still had no water filled but
i mean them to a lot lot later
and your mother did you cook over the ice.
Did you know she'd never mean that
she never called the apple pie
and she always had a stove.
Yes he'll stay in your new home
and she go with any other italian then you
know we still didn't have any italian
maybe around. We were the only one mile
at that time later on some did can
but never anyone close close to was not
within walking distance must have been hard
at the child growing up having who did you
play with like surely life would be very
lonely. I remember life of being lonely.
Because we had i had no other children
to play with how many between you
and there was too between my
brother and i but i was the one
that was always getting into trouble and
he was a little chant mine you know.
I think i think he is that sees me and
then i told him so then he began tell mum
and i was always in trouble. I was law in
trouble. What kind of punishment people.
I she didn't even know she actually give
any other except for you. Yelling at me.
I think or certainly a lot
of that. Were very much.
Kids were seen and not heard
you know good very much
that they had in them to actually my father
and their little into my life. At all.
But i distinctly remember
when we were still up in the old place
that's where my other sister my elder sister
got married from
and my brother had made friends with these
power members they had two daughters who
were deaf and dumb retrying ruby
and one of them get the most beautiful
quite a shrink very fine stuff
that i never seen but i haven't seen
anybody even if i haven't seen since and.
Down some whether they had asked to do
what i magine they asked to do what might
pay them. She done all this question from
my sister who was going to get married
and that when it
when the got home i put it all out
on the bed it covered the whole bed
and up onto the pillows and
it was absolutely beautiful
and my sister had all this and i have
nothing. So i really put on a tantrum.
I mean ask do you see an i can remember
telling us i'm glad you're going to get
married then why we won't have to fix you
take me my whole life you cutting your
good fortune. Anyway i think they gave
me want to keep me quiet in the end
but i can still remember how i normally
go. And she had all these years.
It was unbelievable to see it and
never having seen anything like
that how i can be really you know i was
nearly eight me because she she got married.
And you no doubt of receiving
you. She would have been 20.
But i mean i can still see it.
I can really still see it you know
all this treasure and i had nothing
and what was what was she having done to
her to well apparently she'd been to the
dentist before c and i think
she needed more feelings
but she decided she wasn't going to happen
because she was getting married soon so
i said when we do met
spend the money on her.
But the other tellings in the community
the ones that you did come across.
Did you understand each other.
Were they speaking the same time.
And yes the mourners at that time more
or less came from the same
place from northern italy
that could have been sicilians
that i didn't come in contact
with them so i really don't know
but probably this assyrian would have
spoken italian in a few italian which my
parents would have understood.
I didn't at the time i do now
but at the time i wouldn't say
your parents taught you a dialect.
Well i didn't actually take. And
all if we were just $5 at home.
It wasn't actually taught me what how i
picked it had enough i wouldn't have a clue
really because i can not very
complicated the conversation
i mean if i go to a lawyer most started
speaking very you know there will be words
i probably wouldn't know what they
were but i can make myself understood
and if they speak plain tallien i can
understand that a digital system
and telling people. Yeah she
married an italian from.
Actually he was here before we came
but he was from my hometown in italy to
very much around the home town i mean the
families knew each other and all that
and he had no family no no
he didn't have anybody.
He was just him he came
out like over here. Yeah.
To me it's only time but his family
later and brother did come his brother
but that's all you know
most of the family came.
I think i forgot to tell you carry
and that's the school a coffee camp where
i went to no longer bear it is further
down the road now got
washed away in the flood.
I don't know what flood it
is really what year it was
but they they rebuilt a new one
and all the school records were lost
to some people did have a few photos
and i did have it back to copy camp not
long ago that i didn't have some reason
or other but they did have one of the
photos with all our family three of us
or four of us were going to the
school yes but they had it
when you leave the coffee campaign would
it take you to travel from copycatting to
listen you know we never actually
when the cop came because there
wasn't the road to coffee came.
What would happen was from apogee go off
with a carrier to take in the good there.